how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk
all things mcu and as we get to the end
of this very
interesting year of 2020 a lot is
actually happening with marvel in a year
that really nothing happened at all
but hopefully 2020 is ending with a
teaser for shang qi
the eternals and hopefully spider-man 3.
and get a glimpse of what's to come in
2021
and today some huge news about doctor
strange and the multiverse of
madness now the spider-man 3 hype is
insane right now because of the
spider-verse
but it looks like doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is going to be
just
as exciting as they have their very own
multiverse plans as well
multiverse plans possibly involving
tobey maguire spider-man showing up the
original
x-men showing up and cameos from huge
huge celebrities showing up as alternate
versions of characters that we know
and love but from different universes
where the events of their universe were
different than ours and even though it's
going to be in multiverse of
madness there's a new report stating
that leonardo dicaprio is going to be
showing up as a different
version of peter parker spider-man so
let's break down this
awesome news if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you stay up to date on all
of the latest
mcu news and rumors and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a modok funko pop
so just so everybody is aware how the
mcu is going to work over the next
couple of years the multiverse is going
to play a very big role but how the
multiverse comes into play is going to
be very exciting it's going to start in
wanda vision we know right now that
wanda is kind of dealing with different
realities and she's warping them and
possibly somebody else is warping them
as well
now kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has confirmed that the events
that happen
in the juan division series will lead up
to and directly
affect what happens in spider-man 3. we
know spider-man 3 is going to be a
spider-verse
film and it looks like that's going to
be wanda's doing and then doctor strange
is going to step in to help peter parker
this has already been confirmed and then
finally after spider-man 3 we have
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness where it's confirmed that wanda
is going
to play a major role in the movie kevin
feige even mentioned this when talking
about one division recently in an
investor day he said she'll have a huge
role and that she's filming for the
movie right now so it starts off small
in one division gets a little bit bigger
in spider-man 3
and then gets blown open completely and
entirely in multiverse of madness
and this is where the fun begins the
multiverse
offers endless opportunities there are
infinite amounts of different universes
that they could visit there are infinite
amounts
of different characters that could visit
them and vice versa which brings us to
our awesome
new report about leonardo dicaprio
possibly playing a different
version of spider-man slash peter parker
from a different universe
now this is insanely cool because not
only is leonardo dicaprio an awesome
actor who has been
in amazing films but he almost played
the original spider-man instead of toby
maguire
and the sam raimi series in fact the
original sam raimi series
almost was a james cameron series and
this was the time where leonardo
dicaprio was in talks to play spider-man
but then they went with sam raimi and
with toby maguire
and now according to daniel richmond
dicaprio is in talks again
to play peter parker spider-man but from
another earth
now based off of what we've heard it
seems like marvel studios may actually
be doing a lot of this with a few
different actors and multiverse of
madness there's a report that tom cruise
is going to show up and be playing an
alternate version of iron man
tony stark again from a different world
and originally
tom cruise was in talks to play iron man
before robert downey jr
so same kind of concept as dicaprio
another one is john krasinski
is reported to possibly be playing a
different version of captain america and
his situation
is the same he is one of the people who
auditioned for the role of captain
america before they cast chris evans and
the same is rumored for his wife to be
in the film as well emily blunt she was
originally supposed to be black widow
had to pass on the part and marvel
studios went with scarlett johansson
so you can see what marvel is kind of
doing here and it's actually really cool
maybe all of these characters come from
a universe of what could have been
if marvel studios went different ways
with different actors and this will be a
really cool way of seeing that seeing
what could have happened if tom cruise
was iron man if krazynski was captain
america if dicaprio was spider-man
it's an actual glimpse of what could
have been in a different universe but
there are actually other super exciting
cool things that they're planning to do
as well and as i mentioned in the
beginning one of those plans involves
the original x-men we're talking patrick
stewart as professor xavier
halle berry as storm hugh jackman as
wolverine
all rumored to be returning in
multiverse of madness according to
several sources
including mikey sutton ekikosity and if
we look back we can see that marvel
studios possibly gave this away
many many months ago patrick stewart
revealed that he recently met with
marvel studios he met with the president
kevin feige himself
and patrick stewart actually opened up
about what they talked about he said in
an interview
and this is a direct quote i met with
kevin feige a couple of months ago
and we had long long conversations and
there have been moves and suggestions
which
include charles xavier end quote now
this was really interesting to hear at
the time especially right after patrick
stewart said that he was done with his
character of professor xavier professor
xavier's story had ended and he had said
goodbye to the character
hugh jackman said the same thing he said
that if the mcu would have come along
maybe 10 years earlier he would have
been a part of the mcu but he has said
goodbye to his character they both
retired their characters after logan
however like i said doctor strange 2 is
a movie where almost
anything can happen and you can see how
the original x-men returning in this
film
particularly could be very appealing to
everyone
us as fans get to see the original x-men
interact in the marvel cinematic
universe that we know now
and get to see them on the big screen
again marvel studios profits obviously
because everybody's going to freak out
if this happens and the original x-men
and the actors can return
be a part of the mcu but they don't have
to commit to their characters
and they don't have to unwrite any story
that has been done
because their characters can be from a
different universe if patrick stewart
returns as professor xavier and hugh
jackman as wolverine it doesn't have to
be
from the same universe that logan took
place in it can be
and will be from a universe where
they're both still alive so they don't
have to un-retire their characters they
don't have to undo their goodbyes
instead they could come from a different
universe relive their characters one
final time make a quick cameo and then
that's it this is much different than
coming back to reprise the role of a
character that you once played
now this is a little bit different than
what they're going to do with andrew
garfield and toby maguire from what
we've heard they're coming back
as their respected characters peter
parker from the sam raimi universe and
peter parker from the amazing spider-man
universe
and they're gonna have a little bit more
to do as far as the story is concerned
and helping out our main mcu timeline
tom holland's peter parker and as i
reported before according to
geegositymag.com
toby mcguire is actually going to have a
role to play in multiverse of madness
moving his character from spider-man 3
to doctor strange 2.
right now we're unsure exactly how these
characters are going to get
into our main universe but it looks like
toby could need some help from doctor
strange to get back to his own universe
a task that might take longer than just
one movie which would be
why he's in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and let's not
forget that little name
drop in spider-man 2 in the sam remy
films
science squid crap doctor strange
that's pretty good but it's taken sam
raimi is now directing
multiverse of madness so he has a chance
to now bring his story
full circle and finally give spider-man
a good
ending the original trilogy was great
but there were supposed to be more films
so sam raimi and toby mcguire didn't
exactly get to end things the way they
would hoped
and now that they're both working
together on the same film that is a
multiverse film
they finally get that chance so again
spider-man 3 is going to be amazing but
there are still
many many great things coming after the
film and based off of all of the reports
and the rumors
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to be absolutely
insane so let me know what you think
about all these reports in the comments
down below don't forget to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news be sure to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me